all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thoughts
where I give my thoughts on the way to
getting my morning coffee so
today
um I had a thought about a show I did
last night
and I did a show with Nema
um mima's friend of the show
really great guy
um
and we had a debate on marriage
and
um
you know I thought a lot about
how I am just not in the business of
selling dreams
if I wanted to
Steve Harvey you guys
or you know
sell you a fairy tale
I would say guys there's a happy ending
for most people
you'll get married and I think
especially churches they really sell
they really sell dreams
they're really in the business like and
that's the thing with women it just
seems like you can't really Garner
um a significant audience it's very
difficult without selling a dream
and when I look at the data
I see Zero indication
that marriage will be saved in any way
I would actually say it says the
opposite it says the women are getting
um we're becoming more disconnected from
men and women are getting more
disconnected marriage rates are falling
children
falling and this isn't just an American
phenomenon they want to blame it on
America but it's like
I mean I'm in London this is pretty
pretty diverse City I get I get
complaints from literally every Walk of
Life every country every it's all over
and if I wanted to sound good
and um look like a really good person
I would say
and I'm not saying they're doing this
intentionally but you know but it's like
I would say yes guys marriage and family
is the answer
and I wish that were true
but it just seems like when women get
power we're just terrible with it we
suck it's like we we take the power and
we just abuse the men and I see this
phenomenon
everywhere I see it in Human Resources I
see it in
um
I I see it in
athletics I see it in
um
politics like I don't see anywhere where
women don't do this and I think every
chick and I would include myself in this
has to fight
The Evil Within us and I just think we
have more evil than men I don't say this
in a happy way I don't say this because
I'm happier like yay
but I'm just not in the business
of selling dreams
and if we're really honest with
ourselves
if men really know the risk of what they
were signing up for
um with the value that they get from
most of us chicks
um
most men
would never sign up
never now you can hate me because I say
this you can get mad but
I'm just I'm done with all of this dream
selling
now this leads me to my next Point
husband goggles
what I noticed is there's this
phenomenon
of men making up
to help us and deal with the fact that
we age
now
well thank you thank you now it's just
like this phenomenon see he's like God
bless me it's not always hate on the
streets now it's this phenomenon right
that women just can't we're like coping
we're like oh no we age we get a little
oh this is terrible right and so men
just make up all these terms
um
now I'll give you an example the same
way men will say I like them thick
which really just means
I can't get an In-Shape chick I mean
come on come on let's just call this
what it is and that is the men coping to
get sex right that's the men
saying okay we wanna we want the women
to feel a little better so we can get
sex so the men will say they'll be like
oh I love these old chicks 35 is amazing
you totally look like a 22 year old
and what'll they do the men sell Dreams
they're like yes yes we love these
these um 30 something year olds that's
so my first choice
um because they found one they kind of
liked they're like all right this one's
uh
gotta make her feel like she's special
so then this gives me the point to point
number three husband Gaga
for some reason men have made up this
term
to convince women that as a 65 year old
grandma
the men will find you equally as hot
as you were at 22.
at 65 can you imagine
can you imagine now this is not to say
that he doesn't love you for other
things
this is not to say that
he doesn't you know like other stuff
about you obviously right from any
marriage but
it's it's this is delusion and I'm just
not in the business
the business
of selling dreams I won't do it so you
guys can keep saying what sounds nice
which is at 65 as a grandmother
your husband will find you equally as
attractive as that 22 year old smoke
show down the street really
and there's goggles he doesn't notice
or
you could tweet me your selfies which
are really sad guys it's like actually
quite embarrassing for you
um
you could tweet me your selfies
and shame the men for liking what guys
like I mean the water is wet the sky is
blue your husband noticed that you age
this isn't this isn't rocket science I
didn't
I never I never said he would he would
leave you right so
it's like
I just I just get exhausted guys The
Sims are enablers they enable us to live
in delusion for a lifetime so what we
have is
we have what we have is okay
you see this this is the third third
person I'm trying to film this so
this is what we have we have the women
that get mad and whine and say ah I'm
aging I have to cope with the fact that
I'm getting older oh no wrinkles
wrinkles ah the 22 year olds are hotter
and then we have the men saying oh no
they're upset let me make up these terms
like I love thick chicks I love thick
chicks
um I love these chicks around 30.
um they only like the 30 year olds
because you guys are easier
sorry don't shoot the messenger
um but but
you know
oh and then they make up husband goggles
so
yes you guys can all
virtue signal and say you're so amazing
because you want to convince women that
we're just hot and young for a lifetime
I'll be the bad guy I'll be the big
meanie and say no
husband Goggles do not exist
yes your husband will notice that you
aged yes he's gonna be less attracted to
you
but life goes on and life isn't is
supposed to be about character and
relationships
not how hot you are at 35. don't shoot
the messenger even though I know you
guys will
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and please please lady
stop tweeting me your selfies this is
getting sad and embarrassing I don't
want to see it I I see your Botox
foreheads and your fake boobs I get it
don't want to see it no thank you 22
year old is still hotter
see you guys